you look at this you can get some good
bit of information your self familiar
with it
you notice when you do uh at least get
the statistical variance of certain
numerical columns obviously you're not
going to get that for the categorical
columns so for that we can do things
such as just plot out the values so
let's plot out a histogram that's
Antigua
but I've done it elsewhere too let's for
that eight that department column which
had different values well what's the
value distribution this is a nice you
know single line single line code that
shows you here's what it is if it again
for all of the other numerical fields
here's the distribution walk one we
haven't standardized normalize know that
this is just this wasn't numbers all
right so as you can see o here and that
the salary high medium low the majority
of people are classified as having low
salary medium very few a high wonder why
that is
smoker by they smoker yes or no but then
when you look at the numbers that's kind
of low I thought we had 15,000
what's going on something were digging
deeper into there are interesting
packages in our Python that do all of
this sort of stuff descriptive
statistical stuff that are freely
available everyone will have their
preference or which ones they like one
that I like is called pandas profiling
and when I run that that gives me a
lovely little report we're going to go
back in
up and down on this for a little bit as
you can see it gives me a nice little
rapport with some all of the raw
statistics full information distribution
all that that I want to know about the
data to get myself intimately familiar
with this dataset okay so we saw things
such as missing values that is smoker
98.4% of the column said missing burgers
that's awkward
and then we've got two other columns
times spent the company that's important
we know that's gonna be important that's
got one percent missing and average
monthly hours two and a half percent
missing we're gonna have to do something
about that
it also says he dataset has twenty seven
hundred and forty three pros is that
well the kind of data that this is is it
possible that there may be multiple
people who have similar characteristics
not all of them right it's like two
people might have similar
characteristics based on the type type
of data columns that we have the answer
is yes so we may not you can say let's
not be concerned about the duplicates so
when you see all this so now that we
know a good bit about this data and I
again I know this is laborious but I
need you guys to get familiar with this
data set it's going to be important
correlations how are one column
correlated with another color and you
can kind of see a score for that
inversely correlated to positively
correlated between the colors reading
and blue to red and you can begin to see
such as number of project seems to be
somewhat correlated with last evaluation
here's a nice deep red one average
monthly hours with number of project he
is
eight and so on this stuff is really
useful and to build these sorts of
correlation plots are actually like one
line in R and Python thanks here we are
this stuff and so you can use fancy
software to do this descriptive analysis
or the reason why live data scientists
prefer this command-line Python R is
because they just write one line and you
got it right
it's efficiency it's like a true
programmer will never take their fingers
off with a keyboard they won't use a
mouse because they know all the keyboard
shortcuts that's what this stuff is you
want to do this over and over so you can
get faster at it better at it the more
you do the more practice you get better
you get just doing this that's where you
gotta spend the time so here's a sample
great so we're done with that so let's
move on we need to do some feature
engineering right off its smoker a lot
of missing values what do you guys want
to do with that column this is more he
it had what 90 plus percent missing
discard it and he other take me anybody
second that or have another idiom soul
so just get rid of it
and here one-liner one line that says
give me a percentage of which of these
columns have null missing values and as
you can see is smoker was 98 and a half
percent yeah we want to discard it and
then we have these two other homes and
you gotta figure something so just one
line on that
[Music]
data before discarded the might have a
perfect predictor that history that is
absolutely true
we don't know but when you have to make
some of these choices quickly and we're
gonna see a couple of things that can
help later right now they're just going
by the choice whether on discard based
on the fact that it's missing you look
at this categorical this little
description column here and you look at
that correlation
I'll answer for myself because I don't
know what the seven practices I don't
have them
I literally just look at what proportion
is this what is this column is smoker
and we do you think about if a guy is
gonna meet a guy or gal is gonna leave
knowing whether or not that person's a
smoker is that important and I know that
this this data column is troublesome I
will say I will work iteratively is my
answer so the first pass of building
this solution I will say I don't have
the time to figure out a way to deal
with all that missing value so I'm just
gonna bench I'm just gonna throw it away
for now and I know that I am throwing it
away the next iteration
it makes pass I do it including my model
I can say I have thrown that column out
fix that obviously there's a way to
write back fill that data and we're
gonna do one of those backwards does
that answer your question
question alright so where were we
we got rid of one column the next one
time spent the company which have one
percent missing values for that what
we're doing over here too let's dig in a
little bit further
that's one column does that is that
correlated with something time let's
look over here time spend the company is
that correlated with anything obviously
not by itself but anything else looks
like number of projects has found the
company and number of projects there's
this it's a little deep breath so why
don't we plot number of projects against
average monthly hours was that what we
looked at
number of projects every monthly hours
number of projects so you kind of look
at correlation plots like this and you
make a judgement home to what are we
going to look at so here's what we did
over here you build a box plot for
splitting up the number of projects and
plot out average monthly hours this is I
hope this is visually intuitive you just
took two of the columns and we just try
to plot it out so we took average
monthly hours and that'll be whatever
right well let's flip that bucket back
by number of projects and you kind of
begin to see this sort of distribution
well this is nice what does it tell you
question is or is it for your good
question
in monthly hours that says monthly hours
the question is this column here does
this is this for projects concurrent or
is this the number of unique projects
that that person has done over their
tenure in the company don't know
excellent question
I don't know that's a question that I
should know if I'm trying to get
intimately familiar with the data
presumably again I don't know exactly
whether that would be the last six
months or if it's somehow these they
track their hours which for something
like average monthly average that will
be for the whole tenor if you've got a
time a clocking system or something or
who work with billable hours you're on
the wall firm or so on that's that's an
easy number metric to get for all
employees great questions thank you
in the real world
Oh God I've done 30-plus engagements
never ever I dig it out so you sit down
for me I scream sulky I will have to sit
down with folks from IT to sit down
folks from operations I'll spend folks
in the nursing clinical side and so on
work with them help them tell you what's
what's important then you go back I'll
collect the data then you go back to
them in weekly meetings or so on but you
try putting their counter and do some
descriptive analysis and you say hey I'm
seeing these patterns what does this
mean and you have this sort of dialogue
with the domain expert so you to become
least somewhat qualified to work in
there tonight not an expert but do the
best you can to understand if some
question thank you
anyone else so we see this and we can
see that there is a distinct pattern for
the number of hours that's different
it's not going to be more or less
uniform so to fill in the missing fields
or average monthly hours what we can do
is we can take the average of each by
number of project which is what we do
right here two lines of code and that
gives you a dictionary in Python that
says what's the for those who work two
projects three projects or projects
what's the average number of hours for
those that you actually have data for so
now for those where for those fields
that have that missing go ahead and fill
it in with that average based on
whatever
great question the question is mean
median and mode mean and median are
common ones
Nina's average median is all the data
that I have is at the 50% done
you can go with it depends on the
situation and the distribution of your
data that will mathematically dictate
your choice to say why won't you go with
an average or mean versus a meaning and
that would ideally it's okay to pick a
median if your data is normally
distributed and even though you need to
know what the segregation isn't so and
then you're already calculating with me
but even in there even though you're
looking at this data and you know what
the it's normally distributed diet
around the mean and so on you can still
pick the median because you know that
the data reflects some of it
you're looking at some kind of time
series in so you can say okay the median
there if that makes relevant sense to
the model that I've conjured up in my
head mold is not really used as much I
don't think I've ever really use the
moment does that
this case I'm trying to pick because I'm
trying to I'm already guessing a number
and I'm giving it to them of an average
for a block of people that are similar
to the person who I'm battling the
average seems feels right can't believe
I just use that word very data-driven
feels right then using a media
that that will exactly thank you thank
you that is that's a four-foot you have
a lot of outliers the outliers are going
to skew your average that's the reason
why thank you
dusty where I think this pool just this
one
right that's why we have yes and notes
so that's why we have those who have
left small portion and knows they're
still with the company and the idea is
we're taking a snapshot in time of the
trip is company and based on some of
those characteristics that we saw those
columns of information it's not
comprehensive it doesn't give you their
age it doesn't give you their address it
doesn't give you a certain other things
that earlier it doesn't tell you their
gender gender is also predictive of
whether somebody's going to leave in
future and how quickly they so those
sorts of things you don't have you don't
have everything just have just that
using only that we'd have to try to fill
the model
you presume it's 14 and a half 1 minus
15,000 so that would be
if very good fun we're going to do a
little bit of mention on the reduction
we're into some of that the question was
if I have different classes and they're
imbalanced
do we up sample so basically says you
want to even out those that I have if we
kind of see the sizes even though this
gives you arrange the sizes vary so are
you going to try to get particular
metrics we're forcing these buckets
that's being
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it depends on the scenario commentary
this is just my opinion in the old days
we actually that last decade and I had
to do some of this I did see that I'd
never felt comfortable to do that
because what I felt that I was doing was
I was artificially engineering real
world data to fit certain normalized
times if I'm trying to build a
predictive model that is going to try to
predict off of the real world
I want that data set to be on
adulterated as much as possible that's
just my view when we look at things such
as we're building these of auto machine
million functions when I throw in data
I'm gonna throw in not that process data
set where I've taken out is smaller
because I want it to figure out what
that this that column had so much
missing data is it useful and then I'm
still going to measure its performance
at the bottom line how well did it do it
I looked at the data I could see a
smoker is a lot of missing values I'm
gonna toss that out a minute I feel
pretty
measure exactly see what's the kind of
actresses that anonymity my own country
so it termina build tools like that
working off the real-world data to it
they're not made me kind of with balance
and there's certain features like rapid
minor and we'll see that in the
interface it says do not about this yes
or not just talk about them and they
will do better you can do it and then
you look at the performance you look at
how what what kind of predictive
function you get it does that jive with
reality
you're processing you're pre-processing
so you hope that that process of taking
out the part of the data that's dirty is
standard should I have to do that all
the time
[Music]
the question is where this is important
how much of that pre-processing do we
really do with especially garbageman
progress here's the beauty of it what
those models are doing what those tools
are doing is they're not running a model
of once they're running what we're gonna
do once they're running that
impersonally thousands of times and then
it's early rank orders all of them and
says this one seems to me has the
highest performance so this is the one
in the service so if we could do that
but then we'd be manually doing the same
thing many many times and looking at the
output of the model we were just they
just take a lot of time and so when we
put our faith in these auto functions we
are saying do you figure that out and
I'm gonna trust that judgment that
autonomous process
move forward quickly so we filled in the
values and the other was
Oh just those two pepper is so now if we
look at are there any na s nope they all
seem to be pretty fine
can we here's the test we just don't
have equal sort of logical test
are there any nulls and it should say oh
because I mean I changed this in a sec
but it should be true
and there's distribution the one other
thing we can do remember we had
categorical features or department' and
salary' there is a process called one
hot encoding and that just basically
means take the different categories like
summary high medium low let's take that
one column and split up into three
column timing in love and they get a yes
or no on those for the appropriate value
so for the three salaries if the salary
is high then for high medium low the
values would be high yes one zero and
zero for medium and low right that's all
we do one line command in pandas says
called get dummies and that gives you
the one - cody and when you run that i
don't want to mess this up because i
altered the HR data table but you can
see here is what it did with the
department it split up department to
party department RMD accounting someone
saying what salary high medium well and
if we look at the data as you can see
it's as a 100 coded 0 0 0 0 0 department
sales first persons and sales and
remember sales have the widest
proportion so a lot of money in sales
and same with salary this person salary
is low not set high or medium ok so
that's all we've done and I thought that
process file that I've seen
so now
this is going to get into a little bit
of mundane statistics I asked you to
bear with me but ask questions please
we're going to try to do a little bit
sort of modeling of all of this data
we're not building we're not doing
machine learning quite yet
or it's still sort of playing on the
data and visualizing anything sense for
what fits okay so the first thing we'll
do is what's called a bivariate wrap and
that's taking a look at two of those
variables that we know were pretty
strong red in the correlation map
lucilla last evaluation of satisfaction
level and layer it on the Left value and
so you begin to see and it sort of just
shows at least for this it's the
correlation between we're gonna do that
with a layer on there but in this one
you can kind of see between these two
values where there is a lot of like
correlations coming out
great that's nice let's go on to
layering the left variable and you get
something like this where it gives you a
eat map that says for those zeros and
ones whether the person left or not for
last evaluation and satisfaction level
there's a concentration Roger know what
is this lovely little piece of artwork
please tell me well let's build a
similar artwork for something else like
average monthly hours and number of
projects the same thing with like you
know the shading red red or blue and the
intensity of the correlation based on
like how a red or a blue let's do that
instead of for last evaluation and
satisfied
level let's do that or average monthly
hours and number of projects looks awful
there's no pattern to it like here's the
blue which is or yeah they they left is
but it's over here and doesn't seem to
overlap so this is a really interesting
plot but it looks like you're plotting
in which case it looks as though the
blue is including the red so like you
you can't tell that yeah I don't know if
there's also a Big Red's red spot
underneath it
so do you know of any quick and dirty
ways to try to do the same thing without
this I have fames as well so yes there
are several different ways there are
several tools that help you visualize
the data and that pull that's a subset
art form or data visualization and a lot
of times you don't have to do with
machine learning by visualizing that
data appropriately you'll identify the
trend and pattern that tells you exactly
what you need to know your predictive
model will come from corporate
visualization this one doesn't
does not feel good job but there are
great visualization tools that are built
into tableau Microsoft RBI and so on and
all sorts of visualization packages out
there there are different plots and so
on
that are just there did you just sort of
try to plot that and you can see it
great question thank you alright so this
was nice at this point do we feel like
we've gotten a sense for the data we
know the columns we we get it right
let's switch to rapid miner I promise
you're with dub over crash knowledge
about the program better run
and then we're gonna do this because I
know that it takes about 30 minutes or
so and this is the easy stuff as a
having a Twitter exchange with the guy
who founded this doctorhugo near swap
his PhD thesis work was on feature
engineering and officer of this
automated feature engineering and he was
as he founded rapid minor incorporated
his thesis work into the rock my country
and so what he does here is
[Music]
new process start with a blank
[Music]
he's striking in the corner thank you
rapping minor these guys need better
software engineers okay so what I
already did should be my local
clustering data I loaded this HR table
this was exactly as we had it if you
were to go to design and again we talked
a lot about to needs to visualize and so
on to like rapid minor as expensive as
it is of course we also have great ways
to get statistics and charts and
advanced charts to be able to visually
help me visualize and understand the
data right this is not a rapid minor
class so we're gonna ignore that we're
gonna go into its auto models so taking
that data we want to predict we don't
want to do a cluster in Rockledge want
to predict this left mind you we only
have the raw data set and does this have
is smoker Oh what I did was when I when
I added it in I don't believe in your
place
important data
HR data
and over here if smoker is here right so
that's drop is smoker let's make sure
left is a categorical variable
and let's exclude a smoker
and jest we'll put it here we'll just
call it hrdina finished and it's done
its solitary right so what we want to do
is predict on left and it tells you
here's the distribution do you want to
map the classes to new values of blah
blah blah which is which classes of
highest interest but yes we're
interested in the yes that's important
because it's going to do something
changing and we're gonna see what those
new features that it can cause are going
to be it does say things such as this is
pretty cool correlations what looks like
an ID okay social security number it
would recognize that said that feels
like an ID and it gives me a high score
things such as stability and missing and
as you can see here average monthly
hours two point four five percent
missing so for average twenty hours one
percent missing and we dropped is smoker
so let's go it select all select it all
of that and here's the automatic feature
selection where it will construct new
features and yes it will take a long
time I don't want it to be too accurate
I'll just do a balance between simple
and accurate and I'll have it generate
some new features and then I can do all
of this and that's it
let's nineteen basis that was quick
let's do them all we're going to be
doing SPM so I'm going to ignore it for
now just it's be a mistake to them and
their mother dumb and it is running
and this is it so and let it run it's
gonna take up a lot of computational
power on my machine which is gonna let
this one and we're going to come back to
it and you're going to see things such
as ROC repeat operator operator curves
it will plot that so you can get a sense
of the AUC right for all the different
these models that we've selected and
then for each of them it will give you
like the model simulator performance
metrics blah blah blah we'll get all of
that too we'll come back to this when it
finishes right let's take a look one of
them is done so here it is here is the
accuracy and if we look at the specific
model and you can see by specific you
split it you asked me if it did a
cross-validation
oh yeah it would have to have done
cross-validation if it needed to get
this sort of metrics
and so this is for the naive Bayes model
go back naive Bayes got an accuracy of
87% okay let's keep that in mind just
keep that mind because we're gonna be
building things manually this is what
kind of there's a weekend okay but
they're all these cool stats that you
can get let's go back to our very manual
caveman Bowl where we code this slowly
all right let's split into training and
test sets if somebody does anybody have
a question like how many what percentage
to use for test training or validation
as well it's up to you know because
we're we're comparing not just the
results the question should we use the
same kind of split that dratted Minor
will use no because we're we're testing
performance and process overall we're
not trying to mimic what rapid miner or
h2o will do we're trying to say if
you're going to autonomous then Europe
you're a robot you do everything on your
own I don't want any hints of what
you're doing and I'm not gonna give you
any hints of what I'm doing that's why
we we we dropped a smoker but ideally
would have left
yes yes okay you can serve yes
absolutely the fire yes I think the
answer would be yes but again here's
what we're gonna try to do we're gonna
try to build a model and you'll see that
at the very end when we publish that
train model we're really going to go
back and use 100% of holding us up and
take the model specs specifications or
coefficient weights on all 100% once
because all when you're trading and
split that you do is really intended to
help you identify one of blackthorn of
different algorithms that you want to
say this is the one I want and call it
as my predictive model and here are the
hyper parameters here the weights and
whatnot that I want to use for that
algorithm that's my model and so that's
always the split itself is a
discretionary step
[Music]
multiple iterations ten times ten is
twenty four correct
tensorflow 2.0 hopefully Google when it
comes out its built-in when it does
cross validation it does that even
recursively and all of this is possible
because we think that we're you know
those who build it assume that we're
gonna live in a world of extreme
computational power so why not use it
Oh what I mean by doing the ten tenfold
twenty volts 100 folds 200 folds and so
on and then trying to get the right
points over all of that and then picking
okay this one did well so it looks like
100 folds gives you the right components
yeah that's what I mean there's
I understand the point but for me if you
want to compare apples to apples
so rapid mining is doing like five for
consolidation of them forever
why not I mean you should do it here
it's just saying like next iteration
next iteration
next time I do this I'll make sure yes
sir so you're right it's not gonna be
perfect
there's like I said if you can I hold my
feet to the fire I I cave on that yes
you're absolutely we're all right so
let's do that
I'm gonna set the c42 that just mean
reference to that stupid movie Chivers
kinda galaxy number 42 is the answer to
everything in the universe Maya
okay so one of the things in order to do
support vector machines and K nearest
neighbors you want to standardize your
Americanos and so here is the function
for doing the Senate scalar go ahead and
do that and so we're gonna try to pick a
our first support vector machine
classifier and it's just this using
psychic link Frank takes a minute or two
and it's built it and so now if you take
that model called SVM and you predict it
with the test set that 50% pulled out
what's the accuracy that we get 76.4%
remember the naive Bayes was a little
bit better but this is a support vector
machine classifier very simple it's it's
a starting point right so is there
anything we can do well if you read the
manuals for sve as B C's for vector
classifiers view read
understand mathematics behind it it
juices a kernel there's a trick that
they use where they call it RBF and it
is not a decision for you I think it is
a thank you Ray rapid radial basis
function you did look that up and put in
my notes here somewhere so so let's do
that this is just a term okay so what
we're doing here is now we're actually
trying to fit it we're still stuck with
that original model we haven't done the
RBF yet we try to fit it to see what
does it predict and it says 100%
nobody's left and let's try to use
there's another package called ml x10
let's write did pick that graphically
what does that look like you know the
blue versus the red orange or something
there's low while these are older
packages we are actually using
technology that was available more than
ten years ago
all right and what do we see that
hundred percent this entire shaded move
so obviously this this accuracy in the
prediction model 76.4% ultimately isn't
even something that we can
operationalize just say when you do
operationalize it it'll just say yeah
nobody needs perhaps helpful doesn't do
anything ok so there the RBF is radial
basis function
thank you the kernel trick so let's run
that
and get the accuracy of 90% now with
that RBF for that SVC now what's the
difference
one was a first one that we did by
default was a linear function the RBF is
a nonlinear right
and so obviously nonlinear will do
better so is there a way that we can
kind of predict get the confusion matrix
for this yes and we get to let's do a
bit and then move very very quickly that
same thing we looked at where we looked
at like what how many of it did in
predicting this is gonna try to put it
into a nice little picture it come on
still lying and I apologize even when I
did this at home I have to be careful
because my processors are being used by
rocket miner so so I guess I may not be
rerunning any of it much of the code
yeah
whether the model over trains it's
basically when you get the performance
that's really really good and then you
haven't you know on the test set it
seems to do well if it does better than
what you expected or you're overtraining
overfitting we've got a model that
favorite hits
and then you have to test even more
which is why in a lot of deep learning
methods they don't do the test trains
but they do a test and the train
validation and then a separate test
split the idea is you train a model then
you look at the validation split so say
you go 70 percent train 15 percent
validation and then another final 50
percent for the test unseen you train
with the 70 percent then you use the 50
percent of the validation set to any
Queen the hyper grounders for your
selected model may find use that to
fine-tune and then you test we're gonna
see that we're gonna do that next you
pick some question so here it is at an
RBF kernel we saw the picture earlier
this point this looks nice this one's
looks better so that's great with an
SPCC let's go ahead and build K nearest
neighbors
so I think I mean you got also a little
research I have internal it searches
look if you really want absolutely it's
a question so even with these original
psychic learn packages and functions the
hyper parameter tuning you can actually
change certain selections for an SDC
like the kernel trick the RBF that we
did there are other things that you
could also modify and change to give it
a better a lot of those things and
there's there books that if you wanted
to master just scikit-learn you could do
this with just scikit-learn then you
understand all of the mathematics
everything behind but we're trying yeah
we're we're doing more of a journey here
to try to cover a lot of what I'm so
we're so we're gonna get past we're
gonna leave SBC behind and let's try to
about 10 years neighbors same thing I
then I won't bore you if you just do a
key nearest neighbors they're just
neighbors equals three that's one of the
hyper grounders that we were just
talking about we get a bit like this not
very clean right if you increase that to
25
what sort of this accuracy when from
90.6%
to 91.2% but you can see it does a
better job of classifying just an
unsupervised possible
is this a better job classifying right
so let in if you work in the
biotechnology space if you work with
drugs or any products where which has an
algorithm or data-driven
to regulatory agencies the FDA for
instance they don't want black box
outlets a lot of the work that you do in
biotechnology Prensa that have they
submitted in these regulatory filings
those are considered medical devices and
an algorithm is a class for medical
device and so when you submit it they
have to be able to see if you can to say
here here's what's a model and hit great
it if did say a little bit more so you
have to kind of provide visual
documentation which is why biotechnology
there's a preference for decision trees
and random forests why because you can
with those elements you can lay out some
sort of decision tree and you can depict
it and say you know I did a boosted
decision tree or Adam forest I've got a
hundred different trees here's one about
here's a picture one and you can kind of
show what I want that's why you'll see
this pretty common in industry so let's
build a random forest same thing it's
effectively it's like a decision tree a
lot of different decision for use and
here's the output you can see that
because decision trees are very if this
and greater than that you get these
boundaries that are parallel to these
axes in classification great
that's it openings model said your
training Zoey you're plotting how the
class classification plays out along
these two parties are you just using
these two patterns on that and okay I
just wasn't sure if there was like we're
just about the other set of features
that are not purchased it would just
again we're just playing the data really
so great and even with this there's a
tool that unfortunately does not no
longer works on my machine this poll
graph is funky package it's not
supported it was open source and like
all open source project when somebody
who's been working on it it gets a
better job or wins the lottery and I'm
over working on it and it goes away side
so this graph is has not been updated to
support the new api's within the Mac
os10 mojave operating system so I'm out
of luck I had some pictures with similar
dataset that I was able to get and
here's what it looks like if I were to
look at one decision tree
and then also a graph this is Oh which
one yes no these are these are these
brown dynamically oh this is just we're
cutting the second one it's just a
psychic learns I whatever image graph
graph until they come - to learn math
without its I'm sorry type of it I'm
using [ __ ] thank you
these are not popular classes so this is
graph is anyway it doesn't work so now I
don't know how long we spent out this is
I'm gonna try to speed it up let's
actually build some models all right
we can select I've done this because
taking the data that we have
this is what we these are the homes that
we've got
[Music]
actually no
I did not run I'm not gonna rerun it on
we did the one hot in Cody and I didn't
carry out I didn't run that and so let's
leave this as is so when you do the one
hot in coding you split it split the
data and then we're going in this one
cell here it's got a lot of my notes I
apologize but we're going to select to
run certain algorithms with these type
of parameters for the class part and
just say here's all those models that
I've selected go ahead and run them and
then dump their results in printing so
if I were to run this now this would
take about 10 to 15 minutes
only because I picked neural Nets in
their game
I want to throw it in that if I run it
take a while but here's the opto that
you would get right and so for this I
look at their for the accuracies that
get the average accuracy in the
cross-validation and the standard
deviation and you can see the ears
neighbors does this naive Bayes in the
way that we did it had 64 percent just
to compare 90 days that rapid minor
dings an accuracy of 87% by the way
almost done
[Applause]
all right so we do that and we do some
additional statistics on each of those
models decision to recall and so on
folks if you're never going to need this
is important
go to Wikipedia just search for
precision and recall in there you'll
find this lovely little table that says
what precision recall is after singsong
I found this I've been using this since
2014
I have multiple colored prints just one
page of this table that have it in like
every notebook just to a Wikipedia
search or a precision recall and you'll
go down to definitions it tells you so
what it is is true positives false
positives true negatives false negatives
and so what is when somebody calls power
what's power or power is just the rate
of true positives false negative is also
called a type 2 error it's this you know
it's predictive condition false true
condition is true so it's a false
negative and if you want to calculate
what is a pulse negative rate well this
is how you compute and so all those ease
to dislike accuracy accuracy is sum of
all the true positives plus sum of all
the true negatives divided by the entire
population the truths divided by the
entire population in this confusion
matrix of predictive image
what's fun is when you go beyond of
confusion matrices beyond too much
so anyway for that we calculate some
this eggs and so on blah great so what
we've basically done is what in the
scientific world
it's called p-value happy we're just
running all these bottles and we're
trying to find the best fit because my
data is just representative of the whole
universe right and so that's all we're
doing we're doing all this stuff great
so that's what we do
let's try the reality I've got a
function pairs us after a season so on
there's stuff that you guys can have
let's build a random forest and I've got
code Python code here that just says ok
show me the time when it starts how long
it takes to build these things a little
leery of doing it again because I know
my data said it eternally is messed up
now and you get sort of the validation
plots and what you want to see in a
better when a cross-validation over here
I did I think 20 max depth
I've been depth on this decision tree of
20 you sort of try to block this the
validation curves for the training and
the validation because I did to us and
you want to look at where the curves
split
a little small
you want to try to pick the the max
depth and where they split
so here's six but when I look at it I
thought this is good enough
none so I tried to do you know six or
nine I did that to try to do
cross-validation max 1006
I get output get a plot of the accuracy
results you can kind of see it does
quite well where with this decision of
the random forest with these parameters
for those who leave it has an average
accuracy of just like eighty six and a
half percent or so in this range and you
can kind of measure the feature
importance and so on this is all I
should have in the matter you should not
show me those pictures this is good but
can we do better
could we do better there's one other
trick
let's call principal component analysis
we're just going to do a little survey
here for PCAs to do that to reduce
dimensions
so here were when we do that and we try
to visualize it's the fetus how valuable
each feature is to contribute to words
limits the model and you can kind of see
that you know we're going really faster
how's the best way to explain this
for this can we split some of these up
and drop certain features that really
aren't valuable what are the things we
can do principal component analysis
without going into any of the linear
algebra eigenvectors and so on allows
you to look at all this and serve
isolates here's the here the features
that are most valuable to the others
that are not so we can have and you can
concentrate them anybody have a better
explanation for pcs or strongly
not just dimensionality reduction and
it's based on the correlation so your
brain actually does this matches like
when you're looking at the TV the TV's
in three dimensions but you're ignoring
that third dimension you're looking at
between two dimensions as big as the
most changed most of this correlation is
happening with those two planes so PCA
is like a more mathematical rigorous way
to do that like I said it is eigenvector
I've heard it described is like so if
you have some data that's distributed
multi-dimensional space rotate the major
axis so then the first axis lies along
whatever path has the most various
second axis like what's next
that's very handsome so one so you can
be frustrated that's each of those
rotated axes are the first second third
and so on principle and so that's really
all the way of doing here where here's a
Python code that just says for that for
deselect features that I picked
discretionarily from my feature of
importance chart reduce them and I and
it does that and gives you the first
principle the first component
second and so on as you can see this was
written in British method so and once
you have that you can create a whole new
another data set and then you can build
your random reports classification which
is what we did before and look at it how
well that does and as you can see in
this case the same random force
classification model that we did above
as our train model using our data set
before we reduced dimensions added PCA
and after after is most of them are
above 90% accuracy compared to
previously
didn't even cross the 90% question so
clearly doing PCA helped are we done yet
are we done is that good
can we just say that's good enough let's
just say that's good okay all right
so very quickly the mechanical stuff
let's if you want to build and
operationalize novel called mojo the
model optimized Java object and so on
everybody's got something
these are pickles in pandas and psychic
learning statement as a pickle file so
here's the the model that we had done
and poured that model with all of the
pca is anything let's build it with the
entire data set and then save it to a
dump of that model to a pickle file and
here's model governance for you track
what you call it and give it a version
maybe even update the old school model
model governance from several years ago
now because you're using other packages
there is a versioning control don't
think of some of those taxes that's it
so here it is so now that we've got it I
can actually like again
Jupiter allows me to run command line
and says yeah do I have a peak a little
pop yes here it is
for list of all my files do whatever now
you can save that people file and email
it to somebody else
great to email that and that person
cases indefinite edge of your notebook
and there's a job that loads and it
loves the people part okay great so how
well does this work let's create a
person let's create Steven Miller let's
see if Steven Miller's gonna quit all
right so we create the data set and
because remember that people save the
model have to have those pcs because we
use the PC a rate that's a column as
well so the way you create a series of
object in pandas because that
scikit-learn
works you put in the values and you keep
adding a value of whatever it is one
more series and the last one will be the
column headers right and so voila I've
created the Steven memory object
[Music]
even newer docked height should save
some serious
what question right yes sir just try to
correct it all
[Music]
we just threw numbers in there in this
case your discretionarily putting
something it's a very good question if
you were to operationalize this you
wouldn't benefit if you want to do the
software out of it then the software
engineer is going to look at this and
say hey you did this principal component
analysis that variable how the heck did
you create it and you give them your
code and then the software engineers
gonna pull of his or her hair out saying
how am I going to recreate this is a
transformation of taking available data
and creating that principal component 1
2 into the first second third that I can
then input it to your version control
train models yeah that's right that's
the hard part of software building
working with data scientists excellent
question
Lussier is based on the our run of the
dimensionality reduction and if you're
working it was a whole different package
we use I could learn to do critical
component analysis what if you use
something else what if you were doing
this in a pot identically all of this in
our then ours Burke doesn't have
scikit-learn or had something else and
you were different to them
yeah then here just contribute something
complete different than you are you have
a pollute storage is there
for the new person again I am just I
know what those values are so I will put
that correct correct so if you were to
think like if you wanted to predict
somebody their propensity the
probability of leaving the company
within the first five years before you
hire them based on information in their
athletic job application
but yeah you're obtaining stuff like
this you're saving this kind of data I
didn't even run that here are the
features of steven miller and
okay his salary was initially I said it
as low I said Steve another salary is
low let's look at a couple of things
like satisfaction level is 80% his last
evaluation he got 85% the number of
projects he's working nine projects and
I'm sort of mode it's got to save the
world or change it so nine projects that
he's working on but you know and so on
right and so here are all of those
things now all we are doing is taking
that better pickle file that we did we
loaded it as something called
working model so just run a working
model predict probability for the
features Steve Miller and here's what
you get the zero under one there is 31
percent days 68.6% C Miller please okay
what if we change a few things let's
take him from working 288 hours a month
let's let him work fewer hours let's
take a waste on this projects if he
could only work on two he works on three
projects instead of nine and let's give
99 percent on his job performance repeat
okay
what would the predicted probability
that people need 77% he stays 22% he
leaves
salary doesn't explain with this salary
actually for Steve Miller did not on
that train model that means a proxy for
valuable house proxy further or zip code
and zip code is the most predictive
feature of whether you're going to get
good care at a hospital and whether you
will be readmitted to a hospital within
30 days this is kind of fun major
insurance provider
[Music]
worth well I was one of those scary
people with scary access to human
resources data all eyes because it has
everything of everybody including them
and I could get their blood type - if I
wanted and if I look at things such as
the gender differences in pay scale
women are underpaid but women are only
underpaid up to a certain level when you
reach a certain level title you are vast
feel repaid over your male counterparts
become a leader in an organization a
company you'll be vastly under overpaid
you saw the department's a really good
question yes so thinking about things
that might help your ability to
do your job which would be predictive
analysts and analytics or win of an
employee is likely to leave the company
or if this is going to be used for
hiring can you even use things like age
and sex or is that biased right if you
have to catch provide race ethics isn't
it were always very good you want if you
wanted to do this and if you were given
my HR strategy figure out a way that
identify people this is also the stuff
one of my close friends
we should have assigned all the time as
Susan Matthew who won the John Bates
forest which is a as a predictor of
development
Susan is hopefully she thinks she's
gonna win the Nobel Prize she's focusing
all over econometrics work on machine
learning for that it's applying
economics on the concept of
counterfactuals when you do these sorts
of predictions what part of it
what does it really tell you and if you
brought in that what are those actual
leopards in society that's a this is
this is a salient trend in all of
society well there are all these other
dimensions as well right those other
features alters their their propensity
but that is based on the train data the
data that you had showed something of
the fourteen thousand nine hundred
ninety nine people fifty thousand minus
one people that we had whose records
that we had those are you're only saying
all those who actually left and those
who actually state can you find a
predictive function that explains that
that data set is it real world we are as
you get bigger and bigger data all the
data is the new oil
you know one more data as we have the
computational capability for tomorrow
yeah they sent just a sample and it's so
it's first Miss Agnes is coming yes
yeah I picked one month right here I
think one model which was the random
forest classifier that these map step
six number of estimate here is this
and I saved that and I ran it with the
ended a bit on that for everything and
then I saved that that operational model
[Music]
absolutely I couldn't do that right away
but give me some time I'll just kind of
like put my theorems and hack my way
through exactly that so yes I was able
to find the answer to what the variable
number of number project for the South
Dakota project events so it's it's the
number of projects completed an entire
time and play was at the company not at
the moment it's our [ __ ] friend
kind of makes more sense when I start
think about that that compared to the
context of the project yeah
so in that case if it's a number of
project of the country the person has
done over their tenure that would be a
proxy for their tenure right I'm
interested in the the talk about that
ethics thing I don't have that's a table
that I'd like to go yeah we'll table
that it's question are in the ethics
will see if how much time we have
we'll come back to that - of EF time
let's get to h2o a rapid minor I did see
someone from h2 out here I don't know
still appear but this is h2o open-source
tool and so what we did was run X h2o
remember if you recall certain things
like Bobo said h2o keeps data frames as
these hex files so you have to import in
a certain way so important here's how
you take a look at it it's the same and
what I did was I imported that same not
the processed data found the original
date about know it's got its smoker it
should have is smoker and already
figured out that's a categorical
variable by enough h2o does a lot of
these things even the open source
version very very very well and then
I'll change the to categorical so I can
say it's a numeric vs. categorical
fields it's important that I tell h2o
that that be left even though it's zeros
and ones that it does not look at that
as a numeric field the other way in that
is going to do it any kind of model that
I haven't run will do
numerical regression don't even great I
need plastic butcher zero money right so
make sure it knows that I'd remove its
smoker here and I kept it all all the
others then I create train validation
and test and all auto ml and running
this whole thing auto malfunction it
runs it and it created it does give a
model ID h2 owes own data model
governance as you can see it puts a
time/date stamp on the type of model and
gives a numeric number to each of those
models in physics tried everything under
the sun that you throw at it
this open-source version of each tool
has extra boost which is what win is all
cattle competitions auto ion pairs of
the core algorithms so we run this like
I said this takes about a couple of
hours or so to run everything I pick the
leader model the one that has and I has
it kind of sorted by accuracy what did I
say I guess by default a little short by
accuracy a you see it sorts by a you see
I want to look up accuracy so based on
that sort here's the leader which is the
gradient boosting machine that one has
on the training data you can see the
confusion matrix and other so on the
training data it has an accuracy max
accuracy of all ninety-eight ninety-nine
point eight percent on the training data
obviously that's overfitting but let's
see how it did on the validation the
validation at ninety eight point nine
lower okay you don't want it to be the
exact same and then cross validations
you can see how it does I know it kind
of punches it up
this is what you get for free don't you
kind of get like okay does 98.7 average
here the metrics here you so mean the
mean accuracy of across halogen is 98.7
and AUC is 99.3 scouring history
everything so now that we have and you
can see the feature importance it did
not create intricate left the features
as we headed satisfaction level was the
most important fall by time spent the
company last evaluation and so on we can
compare and fastest to go above the
scikit-learn version of future
importance comeback that and then you
run the tests on it get a performance
and you get a plot as you remember on
the test its area of the curve is ninety
nine point two percent so this is a
really good model this is a model that's
too good you don't want this stuff and
it just happens to be if you found that
dataset yeah this is one of those
problem it shouldn't be this good but
yeah it is and done now what I did was I
tried to see well what would the if I
were to run this on the entire no train
test I just did it on everything and I
think it still were Vincent James it
didn't do much let's so now that you've
seen this version of h2o h2o alongside
the loop run it and you you will see
this in Cuba's sparkling water
presentation when he ran a choice he
showed you it was a IP address it shows
with : 5 4 3 2 1
you can pick up all those pictures
online honest that when you go there
that gives you what's called h2o flow
makes your flow is like it almost seems
to web
all paint or engine and so here I can
call you know it's like a little program
let's this is part of that same we H go
back to the running Python
it also creates a web server to
localhost your machine and then allows
you to access the web app front-end or
that same h tool engine a little bit and
Kara what I did was I just said okay let
me take the updated that HR data I
called this here's the table and let me
do another run of Auto ml and see how
long it takes well that point to a while
yeah build a model and so on you can do
all sorts of funky things PCAs it just
it allows you to do some very very cool
things and this is just a sure what they
clean II make available you just
principal component analysis and so on
all of that's there how do we know that
PCA is a good thing for this side is
that he's linking sometimes sometimes
they can you can't it can't be honestly
paper and pencil I'm just like why not
give kind of results I got take notes
and then show somebody else that's
second set of eyes to say here's what
I've seen there's kind of pattern I've
seen you're trying to figure out this is
little which good model yeah but it's a
PC a good thing to do or so on
write it up share it and get it peer
review the best I can
so now let's flip over to rapid miner
and the bracket miners of accuracy you
AUC as well and you can see a you've
seen for the different models it did
this just a compare and contrast let's
flip over to h2o the leader model was a
gradient boosted machine at an AUC of
ninety nine point three rapid miner a
grand boosted decision tree ninety nine
point two you see now let's go into
things such as for deep learning
decision trees let's look at the model
and here you get there's the decision
tree model that graph this thing that I
wanted to map out well I couldn't get
graph it's obviously open source tool to
open within rapid miner here it is and
you can kind of walk through the tree of
satisfaction hours to a number of
project and then it splits into average
monthly hours and satisfaction and it
actually here's something else even in
the decision tree you look at a feature
sets look what I did
these were the features that have
created so it took average monthly hours
but it creates new ones this one I did
not
something they do
they'll create new features sometimes
today where it is basically what makes
it complicated the feature engineering
is things such as promotion last five
hours multiplied by the law or last
evaluation square
who's going to come up with
human being it actually comes up with
that I want to know how that person is
that that that person's medians huh
this is what the machines do when it
does and Ingo dr. Ingo the founder of
rapid miner his thesis if the natural
thesis was around these sorts of feature
engineering if you look up his papers
and so on he flows into the mathematics
and the mechanics of how we do this he
took that work made rather minor no
different than thirty years ago Stephen
Wolfram one as far as guys on the planet
he took his work and built Mathematica
which is still to this day one the best
Microsoft Word to it's out there one
other thing
you're gonna love this we talked about
h2o the deep learning it did it beep
learning we looked at the performance of
deep learning was you know ninety seven
point seven not always the best but if
you look at some deep learning model
scroll all the way down the rapid miner
is using H tools deep learning module
overview our secret is all the overview
yes I actually I didn't know if this was
going to work so on my powerpoint
I can share this what I did was I
actually took screenshots and I'll if
you guys pay me I will I will at least
get the PowerPoint display just message
me on the
no no listen okay this is the best way
to look at compare and contrast you can
see for yourself
which model does the best and it's
usually extra boost that gradient the
gradient decent piece that's extra boost
an extra boost always wins like cattle
competitions and so it's you can call it
you can run it you can run it you know
Python code arc or whatever here's a
thing you keep playing with that yes
they went paddle competitions but is
that something you can run a company
cattle cattle sorry capitalism is a
competition site it's been acquired by
Google because Google wants access to
people is cold and model travel isn't if
you haven't got a Cadillac a set ups you
just go set it up it will give you
access to data and give you access to
other people's know folks code learning
resources condoms a stock everything to
master data science you can do this for
free the computational we heavy
computational power what not do camp a
Microsoft or Azure subscription and I'm
happy to set you up and you can pay a
few million dollars a year
great or you can do it for free however
if you're a publicly traded company
aboard directors will not like that
they'll say
yeah so many different software
religious methods and approaches that
you do I showed you one I'm going to be
presenting this I presented this to one
company a steel maker and I'll be using
a variation of this with the chief of
strategy for a major matter so go see em
but that's other models other things
I've done were completely different
cross blue shield model is completely
different
Subaru the a I predict your intelligence
built into their engine to somebody they
don't have weekly different the
predicting patients with rare
cardiovascular disease that was of as
you can about hence a decision tree very
complicated with EHR records so it's
gonna have a lot of different and Samba
models and so h2o does a really good job
of building in the Sun one that goes by
the way which basically says you're
taking taking your bigges splitting it
into different chunks of it building
different prediction functions for that
and find that and then bringing it all
together
[Music]
is really good question is there an
advantage for doing everything in Python
versus painting or some of these
additional tools the tools make a lot of
field work easy but my premise from this
talk is if you as a business you don't
have to spend a considerable amount of
money on expensive consultants like
myself or data scientists
data scientists our analyst lovely jobs
they are watch are at college level
analysts and you pay them just as much
you don't need people without any people
with domain level experience so this
stuff that we did with HR this is stuff
that your Human Resources directors
resources managers in your corporate
environment they're the ones who should
be doing this
so the world that I come from something
is like MD or GE
although very Six Sigma oriented if you
wanted a promotion morning was gonna
give it to you you have to do a six
sigma black belt or green belt project
you have to demonstrate bosses
improvement over them at Ferris company
big Johnson Johnson others if you do
that then you qualify for a promotion so
and that was a way to get your change
the culture of your company to be more
data-driven I'd love to be able to see
more machine learning dangers of them it
doesn't matter if you're working in IT
does matter if you're working in
operations it doesn't matter if you're
working the resources you should be
doing this do this for one it's job
security but for others this is what
you're supposed to be are not in your
dead weight in the organization period
and everybody across or thing down eat
three weeks
that's my opinion you can put a big
grain or muscle contractions ethics yeah
mainly like is it a data scientist
responsibility to I was already about
that yeah so I'm talking with my stomach
Gary Mandela he founded an organization
for Shannon reporting combating battling
addiction great organization post Gary
was a prominent CEO of a major
organization himself he lost his son to
addiction with that addiction
it was unlike Gary let me launch okay I
did trunking this having conversations
on that look I can predict people before
they have an addiction event because
forget cancer pretty cute if you take
all the medical conditions they add it
all up they still don't come out to the
number or vehicles that we have from
their addiction today if there is
something that we can do about a weekend
now why I say this I believe my heart of
hearts we can build women here's a pen
model I want to use EHR records and so
on to build this dream on earth I talked
to one of the major kind of the number
one economy Advanta consultancy that
whose name gets dropped all the time
they are non profit group it's already
working with the leading social media
company and they've already built Train
predictive models for predicting when
somebody is going to have an addiction
about that data comes from social media
team you can publicize that you have it
but it's there if you work in pharma
biotech there are a lot of things that
you've built predictive models say
somebody has a rare cardiovascular
disease
this is human life they can't do
anything about it because if you know it
then you have a responsibility to save
someone's lives you know you hear a
publicly traded corporation you could
save a human life because you got this
capability
you better not spend any more dollars in
shut that thing down because if you're
not helping to save you minds then
you've just added a major liability to
your completion so certain organizations
have access to all this data if you play
with people like me yes we do play with
the data we have access to but never do
anything if it's not mandated and it's
not part of your job I can talk to
yes I work for a hedge fund I'm working
on something
I come from the stuff okay stock markets
that you can build great models but
nobody very to 30 minute money Ray Dalio
with Bridgewater
he has taken men he's pretty much taken
his entire trading floor and he is used
it's all algorithmic based now
revolution there few firms before DE
Shaw was the first one to do in the late
nineteen seventies on one of his the
issue is own favorite analyst straight
out of Princeton was a gentleman named
Jeff Bezos and Jeff Bezos built that he
worked on those things and get quite
well and he left before de Shaw and he
shot himself tried to convince Jeff out
of like leaving a company on this stupid
dream of life chasing the internet to
make them online stop hopping anything
goes in finance not anything but do
whatever the heck you want like insider
trading because I have this there's
there laws against exactly what you can
do is high-frequency trading
so high-frequency trading is can you get
certain signal before anybody else and
your training on nanoseconds and that's
been you've done or you know that's been
doesn't like 20 years rain liars poker
back that's all Michael Lewis with a
great book on it it's great I would say
that actually quantitative is a
what more dollars hot before daughters
have plugged into the quantitative hedge
funds then fundamental hedge funds in
the last year I think they managed over
a trillion in assets Oh
but depends on which which firms in
Bridgewater is it to to stabilize
another big one here's a big work for us
is for us as economists all of us so I I
was one of change Mama's kids Jean one
of the novela three four years ago
when the words Fisher market right and
particular want really comics all that
all of that body of work the finance
economics research work that we've done
are based on discrete time events no a
closing price or so on and we've tried
to predict these things in a world where
you have every precise movement of every
equity around the world she would tell
you if I tell you that the Fisher market
means the market is everything for the
shirt on your back right so if you're
working and you've got data real-time
data on every stock price around the
world and every tick by tick and then
you try to find the trends of silent
models and so on the economics really
are very different all of this stuff
that we talk about the capital asset
pricing model is what love that can
probably be thrown out so a lot of
traders will try to build two pairs
training Holton bulgarians matrices and
so on good but good luck making money
very few people are able to make money
unless they have a significant
mechanical competitive advantage like
they are able to get certain signals
before everybody else and they're able
to fine-tune their models on a dime so
it's a combination of all the really
smart trader with experience with well I
don't want to call this a habit job this
time whatever you want to call
this kind of machinery which is called
machine money so it's a human being with
machine money that's where the true
power comes and so you take a physician
the radiologists my wish my are any
artist friend was here dr. Steven he's
one of the few radiologists in America
also codes you can't take him out of the
equation compares up there's an e note
session about radiology and stomata yeah
I don't see how you can take about what
you can take him and give him these
tools all the image recognition and make
him faster and so one powerful change
the world
you're a better job than Steven
we know that if you and we don't want
I'll shut up
it's light